[Música]
estaba viniendo yo por aquí pensando en
el título de esta conferencia reboot yo
lo importante que es que en este preciso
momento le demos al botón de reset
justamente después de todo lo que hemos
vivido como personas y como sociedad
fijaros que la pandemia ha hecho más
evidente y ha acelerado la
digitalización y esto no es algo
coyuntural ha venido para quedarse en
nuestras vidas
durante la pandemia la diferencia entre
pueden seguir trabajando o no entre
poder siguiendo la educación o incluso
en poder seguir en contacto con este
serio escribió no ha dependido de una
conexión a internet y de un ordenador y
también de ciertas competencias
digitales permitirme que comparta
algunos datos las empresas han acelerado
entre 3 y 5 años sus procesos de
digitalización principalmente la
relación con los clientes en el
desarrollo de productos y servicios
sabéis cuánto ha crecido el comercio
online este último año más del 50 por
ciento de promedio y en algunos sectores
como el de la moda hasta el 70% sabéis
cuánto han aumentado en españa los
trámites online con la administración
pública más del 500 por ciento
los ciberataques también han aumentado
un 30% y la incidencia en el teletrabajo
de españa pasó de un anecdótico 5 por
ciento hasta un 34% durante la pandemia
hoy en día todos sabemos lo que es un
zoom lo que es el teams nos hemos pasado
horas bailando jason derulo en el tip
top y ya no hay un solo bar en españa
que no tenga un cuero encima de la mesa
y nos hemos acostumbrado a leer el menú
con el móvil y sabéis que ya no hay
vuelta atrás
bueno la pandemia también nos ha traído
nuevas tendencias por primera vez la
ciencia ha ocupado las portadas de las
revistas ya era hora de hecho ya lo
sabemos de memoria el nombre de tres o
cuatro laboratorios farmaceúticos de las
que no tenemos ni idea que existían hace
un año
los epidemiólogos que no teníamos ni
idea de lo que hacían se han convertido
en auténticas estrellas del rock en
influencers incluso nuestro querido
fernando simón ha ocupado la portada de
las revistas encima de una moto como
mario casas nos hemos vuelto locos o qué
en fin la verdad es que bromas aparte
también han ocurrido cosas muy serias
sabéis cuántas familias en españa no han
podido dar educación online a sus hijos
porque no tenían un ordenador conectado
a internet más de 700 mil hogares
sabéis cuántas personas en españa no
tienen las mínimas competencias
digitales básicas
el 43% de los españoles 43 por ciento de
analfabetos digitales
por tanto la clave para resetear nuestro
país es aprovechar las oportunidades de
la tecnología para cerrar estas brechas
digitales que la tecnología además de
modernizar la economía la sociedad se
convierta en un elemento vertebrador y
el índice de contención de la desigual
con todos estos cambios pensáis que
hemos aprendido algo yo creo que sí que
hemos aprendido
pues que la familia importa más de lo
que pensábamos que la soledad duele más
que lo que pensábamos que preocuparnos
por la salud no significa ser egoístas
que los héroes y las heroínas que no
llevan capa rojas sino batas blancas que
eso de que la edad es sólo un número ha
cobrado un significado totalmente
distinto que se puede trabajar desde
cualquier sitio ya cualquier hora que
nuestras ciudades nunca serán las mismas
y ya no las diseñaremos igual y que
nunca es tarde para reinventarse ni para
cambiar de vida
y ahora que entonces que hacemos pues
hay dos opciones o bien nos avanzamos en
un mundo tipo black mirror donde las
grandes empresas de los grandes
gobiernos tienen todos nuestros datos y
nos controlan donde los algoritmos los
micro segmentan tanto que limitan
nuestra capacidad de decisión donde el
ser humano está rodeado por tecnología
pero absolutamente aislado donde las
face news nos generan realidades
paralelas que nos polarizan como
sociedad donde las grandes plataformas
generan precariedad laboral en un mundo
superpoblado donde hemos sido incapaces
de resolver el cambio climático o bien
podemos trabajar para un futuro donde la
tecnología nos conecta nos permite
trabajar en red y compartir conocimiento
donde el desarrollo tecnológico mejora
la calidad de vida y la esperanza de
vida donde el teletrabajo nos permite
conciliar donde gracias al desarrollo
científico podemos curar enfermedades de
manera personalizada donde hemos
optimizado el consumo energético en un
modelo económico más justo y más
sostenible sin desigualdades y con
oportunidades para todas y todos donde
la robotización lo que hará es que
rebote al ser humano liberándonos de las
tareas más recurrentes y repetitivas y
dejando más espacio para la creatividad
y de qué depende que tengamos un futuro
u otro depende de nosotros más bien
depende de vosotros porque la historia
no la escribe en las máquinas la
escribimos las personas
y para escribir la que será la futura
historia de desarrollo tecnológico de la
humanidad las personas debemos estar en
el centro la tecnología debe estar al
servicio de la narración que queremos
hacer de nuestro propio futuro y por
ello necesitamos tres cosas una
empoderamiento bueno poderío que diría
no las flores por ello para que todo el
mundo tenga acceso a todo el mundo se
puede beneficiar y la tecnología la
tengamos las personas bajo nuestro
control en segúndo protección protección
de las personas y colectivos más
vulnerables protección ante los riesgos
y cerrar ataques y los riesgos la
tecnología pero protección también para
poder preservar los derechos
individuales y colectivos que tanto nos
han costado conseguir como sociedad y
que eso los mantengamos por supuesto
también en nuestro mundo digital y
tercero compromiso garantizar la
participación y animar a movimientos
cívicos y ciudadanos que utilicen las
redes entre personas para un futuro que
está pendiente de creación y ha ocurrido
fijaros que hace unos meses un grupo de
jóvenes americanos alrededor de la
plataforma ready se organizó en masa
para invertir una compañía absolutamente
desconocida gamestop pero poner en jaque
a los fondos buitres
por tanto tenemos como sociedad de
asumir este compromiso debemos estar
todos sin dejar a nadie fuera
por eso no nos gusta la superliga
porque lo que va a marcar la diferencia
entre un asociativo es los valores los
principios y los límites que esa
sociedad ponga al uso de la tecnología
fijaros que estamos ante problemas muy
complejos que van a requerir soluciones
complejas y para ello necesitamos
múltiples visiones y múltiples
inteligencias fuera complejos fuera
prejuicios somos 360 ya no hay ciencias
y letras
tenemos que saber de todo tenéis que
saber de todo
y ya estáis tardando necesitamos
expertos de inteligencia artificial que
sepan de derecho y de filosofía y
economistas o abogados que sepan de
inteligencia artificial porque no hay
mejor momento en la historia que ahora
para crear para inventar nos hace falta
esa mirada de hombre renacentista os
imaginais a leonardo hoy en día con un
móvil con una impresora 3d o miguelángel
por ejemplo con photoshop bueno y
velázquez y goya que estaban cansados de
pintar a nobles y reyes feroz feos y
hacerlos parecer guapo con un filtro de
instagram plaquetaria
el futuro de esta escrito la tecnología
por una parte demostrado ser muy
eficiente en la productividad pero lo
humano es muy eficiente para la
creatividad
el desarrollo tecnológico del futuro va
a ser la confluencia entre sociedad
tecnología y biología ideología así
porque la tecnología normalmente crea
cosas crea soluciones desarrolla
herramientas mientras que la naturaleza
diseña sistemas complejos
lo digital potencia la sostenibilidad y
lo estamos viendo por ejemplo en el
desarrollo de nuevos materiales en los
procesos de la economía circular de la
movilidad sostenible por lo tanto es
compatible que te guste lo tecnológico y
lo emocional la digitalización y la
sostenibilidad que seas fan del for
night un free que de la computación
cuántica y a la vez te gusten las
cervezas de artesanas y las ropa vintage
yo no quiero despedirme sin dos ideas
más la primera es que yo no me atrevería
a decir que el ser humano seguirá siendo
la especie más inteligente del planeta
yo no lo puedo asegurar la tf ligera
inicial de hecho es muchísimo más
inteligente globe en algunas cosas pero
lo que nadie nunca podrá decir es que el
ser humano no va a seguir siendo el ser
con la mayor capacidad de adaptación que
existe lo hemos sido lo somos y así es
nuestra naturaleza y de hecho la
pandemia si bien ha demostrado la
importancia de la tecnología lo que
realmente ha demostrado es la capacidad
de adaptación del ser humano
la tecnología tiende a que todo encaje
en un modelo estandarizado y previsible
con riesgo cero y eso es un riesgo para
la diversidad fijaros que hoy en día la
gente cuando utiliza la aplicaciones de
citas tender mityc lo digo porque me lo
han contado yo no lo sé no lo sé pero me
dicen me cuentan que la gente selecciona
específicamente quién quiero no
solamente por el aspecto físico sino se
le gustan las mascotas o incluso a quién
ha votado no si es de eléctrica paleo o
dieta que tose le gusta el spinning o el
pse o el trx o la final estamos tan
instrumentando tanto a gente que se
parece a nosotros que es prácticamente
imposible que encontremos a alguien
imprevisible alguien totalmente distinto
y esto puede ir en contra de nuestra
biodiversidad y de nuestra adaptación
porque sabéis cuál es la aportación más
importante que tenemos como seres
humanos además en un mundo digital
que somos imprevisibles que no siempre
tomamos las decisiones basadas en la
razón que somos capaces de decidir
aquello que un algoritmo no puede
predecir y que somos capaces de analizar
miles de cosas que no se pueden medir y
sabéis que que precisamente las cosas
que no se pueden medir son aquellas que
realmente importan en la vida muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]